the big guy is giving a big denial
despite an IRS whistleblower providing a
text message that points to dad being in
the room while Hunter was shaking down a
Chinese businessman Joe Biden is still
denying that it ever happened
[Music]
uh what a life and the view thinks we're
all just misinterpreting the hunter
scandal
Hunter Biden's story
to the story of a Father's Love and Joe
Biden has never and will never give up
on his son son Hunter and will never
treat him lesser than and so he is a
father first take it or leave it he's an
addict he's had this addiction for many
years and to various things and I wonder
where our compassion is that's very
touching Dana usually the view only
cries when the Green Room runs out of
krill
so do they have a point are they doing
that thing where they're using the
addiction as a like a a protection
against any criticism well if you've
noticed in the last 48 hours is when
this line about hunter's addiction has
come back into fashion what happens you
know how there's that Democratic bat
signal that goes out it's like okay now
that he's pled guilty to these two
misdemeanors everybody deploy the
addiction defense when was the last time
you heard that we talked about Hunter
Biden all the time they're asked about
it often and it is true yes he was an
addict it also is true that it is just
impossible to believe and maybe not
believable that a father of a son who he
loves so much a son who is addicted
would not ask his son how are you doing
what are you doing today what's your
purpose in life today what are you
getting up to do how the hell are you
making all this money and stop using my
name to get it like like some certain
what kind of a father doesn't ask
where's the tough love I have some
friends who have been through this with
their children and it is a
heart-wrenching thing sometimes the
tough love is just got to be the hardest
part of it the worry all of that but
there are also consequences I would
think that everyone should take a look
there's many things written about this
but Byron York at the Washington
examiner is in a really good interesting
piece about whistleblower number two
because it is curious if this goes all
the way back to 2014 and 2015 and he
wasn't paying taxes then but he only has
to deal with the tax misdemeanors from
2018 and 2019. no one in America would
get that deal right for somebody like
Hunter Biden so there does seem to be
something there and I know the White
House would love to say case closed this
is over and a father loves his son but
it is just not going to cut it no and
you know judge what gets me about that
excuse is that you know it's it could be
a real excuse but we know it's not
because clearly Hunter is incredibly
competent at raising money not only yeah
you it can't be a drug a complete
absolute incapacitated junkie if you're
raising Millions for the big guys yeah
it not only that but he's raising
millions in countries where he doesn't
even speak their language so maybe
there's a certain language that's all
that's necessary Biden future president
vice president and you know the truth is
that the the 20 uh the unclassified
document what was it the 2013 10 23 10
23 right that that wasn't classified
there apparently is a tape of the
president of Barista saying um you know
I gave him giving you five million
dollars each and James for that I want
this now we don't have those tapes but
the the person who says it is someone is
very credible and was an FBI informant
for a long time if they got that money
within 10 months in 2017 and 2018 those
are the years that they pled guilty to
the tax uh for charges so you've got 5
million each there and if you know what
if Joe such a great father why are there
all these llc's being set up is that a
sign of Love why doesn't the father say
why are you giving money to your sister
your ex-lover your sister-in-law you
know all the kids and finally let me
just say that as it relates to Joe Biden
and his love for his son it really is
love for the family and money that they
can get and what I want to know is why
there isn't a why they haven't started
impeachment whether it's for Garland or
whether it's for mayorkas and and I I
throw myself back to mayorka so though
he's not in this segment because we went
through the whole thing what happened
don't the Republicans have the husband
or whatever to get it done and now that
what about mallorcas this guy lied and
and Garland lied you know what Jesse uh
we're the Republicans are down by two in
impeachments and and the judge is right
I mean it's like I'm I'm not a
pro-impeacement person but they have it
coming now and I'm thinking when does
your show premiere it's July 8th 17th
what do you think about an impeachment
that day to help with the ratings let me
talk to McCarthy about dialing up some
impeachment I have his number we'll get
him on the horn during the break okay
good so
how does a crack addict set up 17 shell
companies how can you be so blasted on
crack that you can set up 17 shells and
then take hundreds of thousands from
barisma loan it to the Chinese shell
company and then have the Chinese shell
company loan you the money back so you
don't have to pay taxes man if you can
do that on crack pass me the pipe here
you go
the bidens now have a new message that
just dropped this is from Hunter to the
Chinese the bidens are the best I know
at doing exactly what the chairman wants
from this partnership
who was the chairman oh he was the head
of the Chinese Communist Party Energy
company that was trying to take over the
entire world and then who were the
bidens plural is it Hunter is it is it
four fingers is it the chin no it's Joe
that's what makes it plural and then you
have him basically threatening to shake
down the Chinese while his dad's in the
room pay me millions or else you're in
big big trouble so finally the media is
starting to catch on finally they're
starting to ask him about this it's
about time and then you find out that
the Department of Justice tipped off
Hunter to search warrants now imagine
someone at Justice Trump they're coming
to Mar-A-Lago tomorrow
they'd be in isolation right now and
they're blocking felonies they're
running out the clock come on Jessica
answer this question what is Hunter's
job
he's a consultant for what
anything anything all right that's your
answer it is no one is defending the
character of Hunter Biden I am again not
seen a Democrat do that everyone says
sleazy this is about Joe Biden well but
you just asked me what Hunter's job was
and I'm telling you that Hunter Biden
went around the world to get money
feeding off of no that wasn't what I was
gonna that isn't his job yes it is
now
all right let me melon scoop this for
you guys okay I hear a lot of apparently
rumored
Etc we see the hits Jim Comer doing it
Nancy Mays and you just said there's
apparently this tape get the tapes get
the stuff that's something that we have
like Donald Trump now we have him on
tape right we had the whistleblowers
corroborated by an IG that's what
happened with the first impeachment
second impeachment I abused typical they
well there are so many yeah they were
very complicated
the American public
even for all of the ramp up in terms of
discussing this does not care oh we
haven't started we're just ramping up
now well that's a shame because this has
been going on for months and I'm bored
she did Russia for two and a half years
four years
let us give us time to wrap up
our own Rampage
I'm I'm going to show up every day no
matter what but I'm telling you that the
people at home who are thinking about
who they want to be their elected
officials Etc it's not registering for
them they are not caring about it they
are not saying that this is anything
because something to do with the Sun but
it has been you just said the mainstream
media is talking about it now they're
just starting like an hour ago okay you
know what when it becomes the number one
issue in the general election I will I
will eat my words my hat what a whisper
for a whole episode so no one can hear
me it'll be great that's what I'll give
you all right we got to move on hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now